les spectateurs se sont laissés emporter
par les rythmes latinos du conservatoire
de plaisir lors du festival escales
d'ailleurs une dizaine de groupes a fait
voyager l'auditoire toute la journée de
la chorale au swing en passant par du
rock ou de musiques du monde
aujourd'hui on a présenté un
répertoire
latine et aux caraïbes faisant un clin
d'oeil à la guadeloupe à la martinique
à cuba est ainsi qu'au brésil la gt gt
au village était en voie de l'enquêté
aux antilles j'étais dans les îles quoi
aujourd'hui j'ai voyagé quoi un
répertoire exotique à l'image de la
diversité culturelle de la ville plus de
40 ethnies différentes cohabitent
ensemble à plaisir c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui a motivé la création de ce festival
des arts du monde il ya déjà quinze ans
c'est de réunir tout le monde puisqu'on
a la chance d'avoir ce parc magnifique
qui nous permet de réunir plus de dix
mille personnes sur une journée
véritablement plaisir est tournée vers
la culture vers les spectacles et vers
le rassemblement humain c'est ce qui
m'importe le plus c'est que plaisir soit
ya la dimension de fait la dimension
humaine et qui dit fête dit bien sûr
jeux et animations par endroit les
visiteurs se sont envolées grâce à une
grande roue écologique ou se prenaient
pour des pirates
on vient tous les ans
coup de chaud pour les enfants c'est
celui-là qui voit ses escales d'ailleurs
donc c'est tous les potes de plaisir
tout ça il ya beaucoup d'activités ça
bouge beaucoup c'est bien le genre de
rendez vous pour la saison estivale le
parc du château de plaisir n'a pas fini
d'accueillir les curieux des pièces de
théâtre seront notamment joué du 30 juin
au 2 juillet
[Musique]